And I'm also really
interested in bslib.
I've actually started playing
around with it a tiny bit
before in the previous project.
I think there's a
lot of potential
there. For my presentation today.
I was I would
actually like to talk
to you more about how do you
actually do custom solutions.
So it's very common in
Shiny that you end up
having to create
custom components,
create custom widgets,
that you end up
having to style them again.
But because they aren't,
there's no package for them,
it's not part of base Shiny,
you end up having to do
your own custom styling.
So with that, we
can get started.
And I will
just a quick
introduction about me
have been a Shiny
developer with Appsilon
for closing in on
three years now.
Before that, I was a web
developer for the better
part of eight years.
So there's a lot of the
skills that I actually
got as a web developer
kind of translates
very well into Shiny.
And also I'm an open source
creator and contributor
with Appsilon as well.
And you can reach me in
any of those social media.
So if you'd like to check out
my codes, take a look at GitHub.
If you just have a question
or would like to get in touch,
you can also reach me.
So for today, I will give
you a small introduction
of what css is.
In case you don't
know, I will also
talk about the
different ways that you
can actually add it to Shiny.
I will talk a bit about SASS and
sass, a package from RStudio.
I'll give you a short
introduction just
to get you started and also
how you can use it to change.
So like a very
quick introduction,
the crash course to css. So what
is? css is basically
how the internet
describes the way
that elements are
displayed on a page.
Basically, it lets you
control multiple elements
by the usage of
classes and selectors.
And basically, it's made
of very small instructions,
which are called statements.
Statements simply do two things.
So they identify an
object on the page
and they declare a value
for a specific property
of an element.
So this is a very
simple example of what
this css statement would look like.
So you can see that
we're styling something
that has a class of
search box and we're
styling the border
into the background
of that specific element.
The cool thing, with
css is that if you
have two elements, certain
elements, or 50 elements
with this specific
class, they will all
be affected by this
specific group.
So why is this really
important for Shiny?
The thing is, every web page right
now in some way or another uses
css and Shiny
is no exception.
So even though you're
programming an area
and you're building
this Shiny application,
behind the scenes,
what's actually happening
is that Shiny is
generating some Javascript,
some HTML, some css.
And the key part
here is the css.
So because some css
is being generated,
we can also add our
own on top of it.
So how would we actually
go about doing this?
So with Shiny itself, there's
three very specific ways
that you can do it.
So you can add the styling
directly to your tags
when you're building
your UI. You can add it as,
let's say, a separate
tag in the header
of your page or
your application.
But you can also store it in files
and link those files directly
to the Shiny application.
So for the first one.
Whatever you create
in your UI, as long
as it's an HTML
tag, you can always
pass a style attribute
which lets you basically pass
any kind of css statement that will
affect that specific element.
So here
there's no statements, there's
no classes, there's nothing.
This is style that
you want to apply
to that specific to
that specific element.
And this is fine, this
is OK, but to be honest,
this is probably, this should
be your last resort when
it comes to adding css to Shiny.
The truth is that
by adding, it's fine
if you have one or two elements,
but when you get to 10,
20, 50 elements, then you
start having very complex UIs.
You lose track of where you
styled the specific thing.
You cannot reuse any rules.
So if you have three titles, you
need to style the three titles.
It's very hard to
keep consistency
between all the elements.
This is something that if you
use bslib, for example,
it's hard for you because
there's general rules that
affect every element.
But if you're doing
these individual changes,
you won't be able to
actually keep track of them
as your project grows.
The second way would
be to add css to your headers.
So this is slightly better.
This is you can add a style
tag with some text inside,
and that text can be css text.
This is slightly better.
This does mean that you
can use those selectors.
You can apply the
same styling to a lot
of elements at the same time.
But at the same time,
you won't really
be able to leverage
the browser here
because you're generating
the css whenever
the page is created.
This actually means
that your browser
won't be able to cache these.
So by caching, I mean
saving them for future usage
when you reopen the
application later.
So you end up having a
slightly better approach,
but at the same time, it's
still not the ideal approach.
So we can always do
the third option.
So this would be to
create a file with all
of our css inside,
link this file
to our Shiny
application, and then
the browser actually
has something that it
can save for the future.
And at the same time,
we have a specific place
where we have all our
styling neatly saved away
from our code, from our logic.
This is much better.
This is probably the
best, the best approach
you can take.
if you're using
just regular css.
You can reuse the
code, you can use
the rules, you can cache
these files in your browser,
can leverage the
cache to actually save
these files for later.
It also allows you to
separate your styling
into multiple files and
atart adding a bit of
structure to how you're saving,
styling for different elements,
for different modules.
However, css
is still something
that can get very complex.
And it's kind of this thing
that grows out of control very
fast as your project grows.
So there's still a bit of
room for improvement here.
So one way that you can improve
this workflow even better
is to use SASS.
So sass is, as Tom mentioned
before, this is a language
built on top of css.
And the idea here is that
it's preprocessor to css.
So any sass that
you create always
ends up being css.
But there's this layer
of abstraction where
you have a few different tools.
Then you don't
really need to worry
about creating very complex or
managing very complex css
because sass just gives
you a couple of ways
of managing it a bit better.
So a couple of differences
here between sass and css
are sources are object oriented.
So this means that
you can have nothing.
It's more about
the concept of what
is a specific element that
you're trying to target,
not the specific element
that you're targeting.
It also allows variables.
I know that css community is
actually pushing forward
with variables in css.
This is, I think,
a very nice bonus.
But it's one of the
things that sass,
at least in my
understanding, still does much
better than just the css.
And also, you can always
use sass to actually generate
variables, two or three
years in the future.
So a couple of really
interesting things that
you can do with sass,
so we talked about nesting.
So what nesting
means is that you
can simplify a lot of the rules
that you do by nesting them.
So as you can see css
on the right side,
doesn't really allow for this.
So if you're targeting two
different elements in this
case, for example, a UL and
an LI elements inside
of a nav bar, you're going
to need to create the full
selecter
every time you create a rule.
Sass kind of solves this
by allowing nesting.
So if you have two elements
inside the same element,
you can kind of nest them
together and simplify
your code even a tiny bit more.
We also talked about variables.
So css does allow variables,
but sass does it in a way
that you can kind of
declare them, even in separate
files, completely different,
there is no scope required,
which is something
that css variables need.
And you can simplify them by
assigning a name to a property
that starts with a dollar sign.
And then just this
becomes a variable
that you can use
throughout your code.
It also has two very
important mechanisms
which are extends and mixins.
And so extends, this
kind of, and this
is something that is very well
explained with an example.
So it basically
allows you to share
styles between
selectors and the way
that you would do this
normally in css
if you would have two elements
that you would like to style,
even though they
are very similar,
is that you would simply do
the styling for both of them.
By using extend
you can actually create
a partial part of code
by using the percentage
as a marker for the name
of that block of code.
And you can then
extend for each
element, you can simply
extend the name, the extend
rule that you created,
and the code will actually
be copied into that selector.
So this means that you
can reuse parts of styling
that you use very
often by simply
extracting them into a separate
name that you can then reuse.
the second one is mixins.
So mixins are
slightly similar,
but these days work
more like functions.
So the idea here is that
instead of simply taking out
a piece of a block of code
and saving it with the name,
with a mixin and you're
actually having a function.
So this means that you can
pass specific arguments
to those functions
that you're creating.
So in this case,
for example, we've
identified the only difference
between these two components
is actually the smaller size.
So we can create a mixin and that
has an argument of border size
and simply call those functions
in each of our declarations
for each specific element.
So small introduction to sass,
of a very big
a crash-course
kind of thing,
but hopefully it shows
you some of the advantages
that you actually have.
So how do you actually
use this with R?
So the best way, of
course, to use the sass library
and RStudio was kind
enough to actually create
a really nice package for us.
So you can use R/sass
to not have to worry
about all the preprocessing.
You just need to write code.
This is all you want to do.
And in general, the
package gives you
one big function called sass,
and this function can take
either a string or a full file
and just return
the css to you.
So all of these techniques
that we've been talking about,
you know, have access to them
inside of R directly
without having to,
without actually having to
work outside of R files.
The second way is
actually you can actually
pass its reference to a file.
So here, for
example, we're simply
pointing the cells function
to our style's main file.
And this file has a lot
of internal stuff for sass.
And this way, you can kind of file,
you can kind
of split all of your styling
into something that behaves
a bit more like code managing
and actually lets you
reuse a lot of the styles
and kind of keep a
grasp of styles when
it comes to a very big project.
A second argument
that's very important.
And this function is the output.
So the output will generate
that css to a specific file.
And then this is something that
you can simply add to your UI.
And now you have all of your
styles saved in a project,
in a project folder
structure that
has everything well sorted, then
you can kind of manage them.
If you would like to
see an example of sass
being used very extensively,
I will point you to my Shiny
contest entry from last year.
I used sass quite a lot,
and hopefully it will
guide you in the right way
to get started.
And I think my 15
minutes are up,
and I'd just like to
thank you for this.
And I also I know that the
slides will be available later.
So I've also added a
couple of resources
here to get you started with sass.
And in case, you really
want to get into css,
there's also a couple
of bonus slides
with some of the
selectors that I
think are at least the
basic ones that you need to
for css.
So hopefully this
will get you started.
And in one year,
you'll be thinking, how
have I been using css without sass?
So let's talk about speeding up Shiny apps.
So small disclaimer, this is
going to be just some of the,
I think, very important
details that you always
need to take care of.
It doesn't mean that you'll
be able to speed up everything
using just the steps,
but hopefully it
will get you started when it
comes to at least identifyng
some of the issues that
your Shiny app might have.
So I'm going to talk about three
very important details when
it comes to speeding up
Shiny applications.
The first one is
update functions.
I'll also talk a bit about proxy
objects and proxy functions.
And then I will finish up by
letting you know a bit about custom
messages and offloading.
I won't get into
too much detail.
And of course, every
package is different
and needs different
types of optimizations.
But hopefully this will
help you get started.
So update functions,
what are these functions?
So update functions are
very simple
functions that
let you update
existing Shiny widgets,
so the important thing here
is that base Shiny has these,
but it's very possible that
you're not always using them.
So as an example, we have here
a very simple Shiny application
that has just a
checkbox and a dropdown.
And you can see that in
our UI, we define checkbox
and we define the UI outputs.
And then in our server
we simply observe
that a checkbox, and we
change our select input label
and values depending on
the state of the checkbox.
This is very standard.
This is simple.
This is something
that you probably did
quite a lot of times already.
However, you can see
that we're not really
using any update functions.
So what do I mean by that?
What's happening here
is that every time we
trigger a change
with the checkbox,
we're actually re
rendering the dropdown.
So you can see that because
we're using a UI output
and then filling in that UI output
with our dropdown, what's
actually happening
behind the scenes
is that whenever this
output changes, Shiny is
removing all the
bindings that it creates
is in the background.
It creates a new set of bindings
for a new dropdown that just,
it does have the same idea, but
it's a completely new dropdown
and has to rebuild the
whole structure, so this,
we can probably do better here.
And this is where update
functions come in.
So if we simply
change our codes to
instead of using a UI
outputs to simply
render select inputs,
and then instead of
filling in the UI output,
we simply use the update
select inputs function.
This is completely different.
So in this case,
what's happening
is that there's a call
from Shiny being sent
to the browser that says, hey,
update this specific input
that already exist in the
browser with a new label
and some new values.
So you can see here that
these are very small changes,
but it's already
slightly different approach
to how we're actually
building the application.
Does this really matter?
And just to give you an example
of what kind of improvements
we're talking about,
the difference even
for this simple drop
down, is actually
that for the page
to be completely re
rendered and ready
for the user to use,
it goes down from
15 milliseconds to 10
milliseconds.
So just the simple,
and we're not even talking
about the very complex thing
that we're doing here.
It's just a simple drop down.
It's already a
massive improvement.
So you can imagine that
if we're talking about 50
drop downs, 50 elements that
will be re-rendering these really
add up, add up very quickly.
So why is this actually better?
Like I said, the update
function is actually
just sending a
message to the browser
and then updating
that specific element.
So there's no need
to rebuild anything.
It just uses the bindings
that Shiny already created
for this specific element.
But when it comes
to update functions,
these are present in most
Shiny widgets out of the box.
So if you're using
even just base
Shiny, any kind of
input that you create,
it probably has a
corresponding update function.
So action buttons
always have an update
action button,
select inputs always
have an update select input.
And you can see
here that there's
a bit of a standard where
the update function is always
the name of the UI definition
of the widget with a prefix
update.
Of course, always make sure
to check the documentation.
Usually these are linked
the bottom after the function
definition, you have
some information
about what kind of
updates actually exist
and what kind of
arguments can actually
be updated with that function.
So these update
functions are nice,
but what happens when we have
slightly more complex widgets?
And this is the case
of when you have,
for example, the DT table or an E-Charts chart,
or a Leaflet map, these all
work slightly
different because we're
talking about very complex,
very complex widgets,
that a simple update
function is probably not
enough for everything.
So this is where
proxys come in.
So proxys are basically a
way to reference an existing
widget, an existing
complex widget,
and then usually they
have their own set
of functions that behave
similar to update functions
but are applied to that
specific instance,
in the proxy, the instance
of the widget itself.
So a lot of what usually happens
is that, an example is DT.
So you render, you create
your data table outputs,
you fill it in with
render data table.
It creates a table
by using the way
to access the proxy
to that element
that we just created is actually
to use data tables proxy.
So this is a function
that also exists and lets
you save a reference
to a specific table
with a specific id that
was defined somewhere else.
In this case, it uses the same
id as the data table output.
And you can see that
this is basically
an example of how
you could use proxy,
so we define our data table
output, we fill it
in with our render table
and some, in this case,
the iris data set.
And then if we
save the reference
to the proxy of that element
using data table proxy,
we can just manipulate it.
So in this case, we have a
small checkbox and every time
the checkbox changes, we
call a specific proxy update
functions, which in this
case, is select rows
and we just select or
don't select the first five
rows of the table.
So one important
thing to note here
is that different packages
also have different update functions.
So it's important to know to
figure out these functions
whenever you need to use them.
Again, documentation
is always different.
So if you check for this data
table proxy function,
you'll have a lot of
information about all the update
functions that come
with the proxy object.
And internally
proxy actually works
very similar to the
update functions
that I mentioned before.
The difference here
is that instead
of having one
update function,
we actually have a family
of update functions
and an object to apply to.
Again it's important to
check the documentation,
you won't always be able to
update every single thing,
so it's very
important to know
the family of proxy update
functions that exist.
Hopefully there will be one
that does what you need it to do.
If not, we'll probably
we'll actually talk about it
now, which is custom messages.
So if something doesn't really
exist, you can always create it.
And this is part of the
beauty of Shiny generating
HTML, css,  and JavaScript that you
were talking about before,
because the fact that if
you're still working
with the web pages, means
that you can use JavaScript
by itself to actually augment
Shiny, even more so.
What are custom messages?
So when I mentioned the update
functions, these functions
are basically a one way call
to the browser where internally
there's some code being run,
something that you don't really
know, but you know that it's
going to trigger something
in the browser and update.
What's actually
happening down
there is similar to how
custom messages work.
So you can trigger JavaScript
functions from R directly
or you can
trigger updates in Shiny
from the browser.
There's three
functions that kind of
give you the whole
behavior of the messages.
So in part, this is the
send custom message function.
In JavaScript
this is the add custom message
handler and on input change
functions.
So I will give you
another example
of shiny decisions, my Shiny
contest entry from last year.
So one of the things
that I had to do
was I had the
Leaflet map that was
so I had the leaflet myself
that was displaying some markers
is being updated.
That's fine.
There's always there's
an update function
for a leaflet that lets me
change the data that way.
But I wanted to have this extra
behavior of actually changing
the saturation of
the map depending
on how bad you're
actually you're
actually doing in the game.
So I. Isn't something that
is standard to leaflet.
This had to be custom
built, and this
is where custom messages
kind of came in. So
from the JavaScript side,
remember, there's the
add custom messenger
and custom message
handler function.
And basically what
this does is it
lets you run a function whenever
a specific id is
triggered in Shiny.
So what I mean by that is
that it kind of registers
the handler so that it can
be triggered from Shiny.
So in this case, I had this
update map style handler that
will call this update map style
function and the update map
function, it will
create some css
that kind of gives you
that your sepia filter that
gets a bit more evident
whenever your scores are
very low in the game or
it goes up, whatever.
And goes back to
the normal colors
whenever you're doing better.
So now we have some
JavaScript behavior.
And we have a Shiny handler
to trigger that behavior.
So on the R
side, we just need
to send the custom
message for the same id
with whatever values we want
to pass to the JavaScript
function.
So two simple functions,
and we already
have a leaflet behavior that
doesn't really exist before.
As far as a very small
proof of concept,
the way, this is actually
working is that from the way,
the whole thing works,
is that from R you're
sending the custom message
that the message is looking
for a specific handler,
that handler is triggering
a specific JavaScript function.
That's it.
There's no magic here.
So now we can from Shiny,
trigger things in JavaScript.
But what happens if we want
to do the opposite thing?
So we actually want to.
And I just realized these
are actually created.
So the first one is
actually JavaScript.
The second one is
actually Shiny.
So if we have a
JavaScript function
that's doing some
work in the browser.
How do we actually tell Shiny
that something is happening,
that something happened?
So we can use this input value.
So this input value
works very similar.
It has an ID and a
message and what it does
is that it sends a
message to Shiny
that can be observable in the
list of inputs in the Shiny
session.
So this means that our
input value will actually
be changed into the message
that we pass from JavaScript.
So we can just observe
it, do whatever we need,
so we can pass messages
from the browser back to Shiny.
And another example
of something that
uses this kind of behavior
in the same application,
so here I was observing whenever
the user made a choice.
And then I was just sending
using this input values
so that I could
observe it in Shiny
and actually know that
something changed.
So why are these
important when it
comes to speeding up Shiny? so because
these allow you to actually
pass a lot of the time to run
whatever you want directly
in the browser.
This means that you can free
your shiny process to actually
do only the important things.
So if you have very small, very
small changes that are just
UI changes and don't really
need to go to the server.
This is one way that
you can think of them.
It also means that if you have
some kind of code that already
exists in Javascript,
you can actually
just trigger that
code instead of having
to rebuild it in Shiny.
So this speeds up not only Shiny
itself, but actually the Shiny
development, because
you won't need
to just redo the same function
again in a different language.
It also allows you to
extend these functions
that we talked
about before, simply
because there's no need to
write the corresponding Shiny
function, the
corresponding update
function, if this
is something very
specific to your application.
So it's very easy to get
started and very powerful.
Of course, keep in
mind that you will
need to know a bit of a Javascript
at least to get started.
But if you don't
know it by now, I'd
definitely recommend you to at
least know some of the basics,
because it's very, very
powerful when it comes to Shiny.
And that's it from my part.
Thank you.
If you have any
questions, just reach out.